the annual holiday parade in downtown
Summerlin kicks off tomorrow night love
it dancing snow
and Santa Candace Charles joining us
live from downtown Summerlin and oh
there we go you got to stay warm somehow
you have to dance to make this happen
you know what it would seem like I'm
actually dancing to this but it's really
because I'm cold you're shivering lives
you can't imagine here yes I'm shivering
with the holiday cheer thank you Sherry
for letting it just be a little crisp
for this holiday season it's right on
time for the downtown Summerlin the
holiday parade which kicks off for the
first time this season this Friday and
I'm joined by the one and only hey thank
you so much for joining us okay now
besides the parade there's a skating
rink which I know Heather has been
talking about is very excited about I'm
sure John is as well tell us what else
people can enjoy this season so we have
just a variety of things that people can
really come down and enjoy we have the
annual holiday parade the rock rink we
have our Santa Chalet we have the giving
machine so you can come on down make
some donations to local non-profits we
also have Miracle flights light for
flights Marquis throughout so we really
have a whole abundance of things that
people can really do and we're just
thrilled that people come down and make
traditions with us now the dancers are
getting they going they got the energy
right now what is the parade like
because I know there's several different
floats we got a couple of them behind us
right now how many floors do you have
what kind of floats are there so we have
six floats and they're all themed based
off you know your favorite movie so we
have an elf we have a nutcracker float
and then we have a cast of over 50 local
kids and so we're just thrilled that
they can showcase their talents here at
downtown Summerlin all season long nice
Haley thank you so much now if these
dancers are the opening act that you
know who the headliner is the man and
the big red suit it's Santa himself yes
of course I delivered Santa as I said it
would Santa tell us what can people
expect from this experience oh well
there are so many things to see here
these fantastic dancers they are always
so happy out here smiling oh and it's
it's so much fun now I know Santa a
couple people have requested things
again Heather I'm going to get you that
phone for sure but besides that some
cash anything else we can get from Santa
I also would like you know a new coach
Santa how do I get these things well you
have to be very very good okay now I'm
not so sure Sherry has been quite there
but she'll try really hard for next year
Oh Sherry I hope that you will thank you
so much Center for chatting with me you
guys it's all kicks out for the first
time tomorrow Saturday excuse me
tomorrow's Friday I'm obviously tired at
6 p.m Friday Saturday Friday Saturday
every Friday Saturday to December 17th
and of course there is a Hanukkah
celebration on December 21st you get
pictures down here and skating ring give
back all of these great things are going
to be on our website details and more on
Amazon now.com for now live from
downtown Summerlin where the holiday
parade will be this Friday I'm Candace
Charles eight is now the big man said it
yeah Sherry apparently you've had a bad
year what's going on a good list still
yeah sure the next list what list are
you on that was uh Santa throwing some
shade